every time he sings that song on stage
for me I get weak in the knees Priyanka
Chopra is Nick Jonas's biggest fan but
there's one song that really gets her
heart pounding I don't settle for less
than that the actress sits down with
Alex Cooper on the call her daddy
podcast and says it was her now husband
that was first to make a move sliding
into her DMS with a bold message
literally like his message was
I've been told we should meet
how cocky so sexy it was kind of an
instant thing new once we locked in
together that I had a partner for life
at first Priyanka says she wasn't
convinced she should give him a shot but
had a quick change of heart after a
Google search brought her to the music
video for his 2016 track close
Oh So Close
That Body deserves at least a day every
time he sings that song on stage for me
I get weak in the knees
[Music]
one thing Priyanka wasn't worried about
I don't give a we did who's dated
right we're talking about the future
yeah prepaid no mind to Nick's previous
relationships with stars like Selena
Gomez Miley Cyrus and Olivia Culpo the
actress stayed focused on the future
which blossomed into marriage and a baby
he just came into my life at a point
where I had chosen me I was happier I
was healthier I was in a great state of
mind and he was like a hurricane and I
just kind of went with it the two tied
the knot in 2018. I have a lot of faith
in who my husband is and you know that's
such a great feeling to be able to like
lean on someone and know that they got
you and in 2022 the lovebirds welcomed
their first child together Donner multi
it has changed everything for the better
of course and you know I love singer and
um yeah you know it's it's beautiful but
let's rewind to the moment Nick slid
into priyanka's DMS my response to him
after seeing that video was why don't
you text me my team can see my DMs I'm
blushing now now Priyanka explains what
makes Nick so different from all her
former Flames I think he thrives on
seeing me shine he is the most excited
about the shows that I'm doing he was
most excited you know when I'm on a
carpet you know he'll step aside and
he'll take like pictures of me that's
what you want you want your man to be
your champion and that's exactly what
Nick did last month attending the London
premiere of her new Show Citadel I saw
Nick walking by looking Dapper of course
he got the memo too has he seen the show
yet yes he's seen multiple versions of
it
um but sweetly he's going to watch it
again and he was right by her side last
week at the premiere of her new flick
love again where Priyanka thanked her
man for making a special cameo in the
film I was supposed to do the scene
where actor like licks my face in slow
motion oh God exactly just
safe to say this fairy tale ended with a
happily ever after this is my knight in
shining armor
[Music]
foreign